This time we're going to leave the left child unchanged
and build up a new tree based on this new right child.
So now let's test it.
I'm going to make a very simple tree that has midpoint right at the root,
and let's say that I insert atwood, margaret into this tree.
We think it should go on the left because atwood is less than midpoint.
A comes before M. So let's try it out.
And in fact, it did. Here's our answer.
Here's our answer down here in Python tuple form, and here's the tree it corresponds to.
Midpoint at the top with atwood, margaret as the left child.
No right child for midpoint, no children at all for atwood, margaret.
Now let's try inserting zuma, jacob into this tree.
Here is a pictorial representation of what we want to get out.
Midpoint has only a right child. That right child is zuma, jacob--jacob, which I can't spell.
Down here is the Python nested tuple interpretation.
Midpoint has no left child, but it does have a right child: zuma, jacob.
But reading this Python tuple stuff, that's really hard,
so let's write a procedure to walk down one of these trees and print out everything in order.
Again, this is a recursive procedure.
If we've reached the end of the line, we don't do anything,
but otherwise, here's what I'm going to do.
Remember our rule for these trees.
All of my left children are less than or equal to me.
So I'll print them out first with a recursive call,
then I'll print out myself, and then because all of my right children are greater than
or equal to me, I'll print them out last.
Now let's try this out with a little more complicated test case.
I have taken a tree that has a midpoint, and then I'm inserting both Jacob Zuma
and also Margaret Atwood into it.
It would be a rare tree that would contain both the author of The Blind Assassin
and also a South African president in 2009, but you never know.
And now when we print out the tree, we get all of the elements in alphabetical order.
Huh. Actually, if we didn't know any other way to sort things,
this tree could be a way to put any arbitrary elements in ascending order.